Ngày May tăng hành chiến nếu pháp chiêm trong là sống biểu tình và đình gông quy mối lớn, bớt sửa thăm xa của nhiều người nè và tăng lấp sợ hội.
Nguyên biểu tình phản đối kế hoạch tất sản nâng xác của chính phủ, cho rằng chính sức này sẽ làm sản phúc lời,
và ra tăng hánh nạn đối với người lời đồng.
nhiều lĩnh vật công gọt bị an hưởng nát này, đồng nửa sống viên ở thủ đô Paris,
trong một phần bà sống viên tưởng học chiêm quan Quốc, đảm hưởng sản dạy.
Hãy thống sốt thông cung cộng tại Paris, gun nếu tay liệt ngoại dựa cao điểm,
trong khi một số tiến đường bị phong còa, nè cả ngành năng lượng của Mỹ tất đọt,
khi sản lượng định hạp nhân giám, so công nhân thăm xa đình cân.
Một nơi vụ pháp cho biết, ước tính có khoảng tám châm nhìn người xung đường,
một chính phủ về chiến khai cá mấy nghìn kệ sát để suy chiến trở tự.
Để đột xem là một trong những ngày bự tình lớn nhất, kể từ năm 2018,
phà lánh sự bất bình ngày cân xa tăng của sã hội pháp,